gwen stefani and blake shelton got
engaged in october after dating
for about five years but the couple says
they're gonna take their time as well
before they actually walk down the aisle
yeah gwen was on on air with ryan
seacrest
and blake was on k92.3 where they each
revealed that they have no interest in
having a coveted wedding
let's forget well not forget because
it's
active but we know that there's light at
the end of the tunnel so in a
post-pandemic world would you prefer a
smaller
ceremony a smaller wedding or a larger
wedding
well um i would say um
i would say i just want my parents there
at this point like my parents wouldn't
come to thanksgiving because they're so
scared so
um really would rather it not be a covid
situation
like i would rather not have masks and
that kind of thing and
even when you cut it down to just family
it's still too many people for covid so
we're sort of like going to see what
happens in the next few months
it makes it makes sense hopefully
sometime uh
this coming year we can find a window
and it feels like we can start
coming out and mingling as people
again you know and and and and get this
wedding planned but
for now we don't even have it planned
when or anything because we're just like
everybody else in the world we have
no clue what's what's coming but
hopefully it's getting better
angel says congratulations to gwen baker
yeah this has been an interesting
conversation like
with them it's a bit different because
let's say they're probably
maybe gonna have to wait six months
somewhat summertime maybe they can have
a normal wedding it's been an
interesting thing to watch
couples i know and celebrities over the
past year decide to delay
their wedding yeah want to go first of
all i'll have rods go first okay
i i don't know i don't i i think
hey listen it's their wedding they got i
know say they think they can do whatever
they want
and you know it's funny that you're
seeing this as opposed to you know right
after we did the trey song story because
it's just completely different it's like
they don't want to put people at risk
and they want to do it right and they're
willing to wait and that's the thing
like this is their wedding and i'm sure
they want to get married and they want
to
sort of have the party and celebrate but
you know
you can't right like you just if you
can't do it the way you want to do it
then you just wait and that's just the
reality yeah right
yeah but people got very creative at
weddings i know somebody that went to a
gay wedding uh earlier this summer when
there was no dancing
at the wedding and they were like what
can we do
we can't dance ah but we can run away
and they had everybody
who was there lying make two lines and
they did a catwalk
right so instead of dancing everybody
was individual everybody was distanced
and they still got to do their thing but
nobody was within touching distance or
spitting distance or laughing distance
and they just did a catwalk and they did
it for hours
rotate through hours yeah dia says now
that is responsible you show
you show people you love them by keeping
them safe yeah klutz says they're more
rational
thoughts on this keisha you know what i
find this to be
really cool just because they have
enough money
that they could literally take all their
loved ones put them on an
island you know have them self-isolate
have them kova tested every single day
they could literally do all the rigorous
things that we do for television
productions because obviously the
television business is still running in
a lot of ways
and they have strict protocols they
could totally pay for all of that
and still have their wedding and they're
choosing not to and i think the reason
why they're choosing not to is not
because they don't want to just get
married tomorrow i'm sure they're madly
in love
but i think it's because they recognize
that they are two
huge personalities huge celebrities they
are role models for a lot of people
and i think i personally feel like
they're doing this
so that other people who want to plan
their wedding or are kind of itching to
get married
are like you know what we can wait too
they're just trying to lead by example
and i think that
in my opinion is amazing yeah curious
why can't they have a zoom wedding
oh they'll have the party when the
madness is over
no waiting for me till the covert is
over agent says i respect the decision
yeah i mean like we said to each other i
just find it it's interesting that i
know some people i just went ahead
and did like the courtroom yeah uh
wedding and then they're gonna have a
party when they camp because
if covent has taught us anything things
could change on a dime
so i just find it interesting that has
not taught you it's like just go get
married even for the
legal implications if one of you ends up
in the hospital or whatever that
it might be if copenhagen has taught us
anything yeah things can change so why
not just go ahead and get married
because
you know some couples i know are now
going to be waiting probably
an extra two years before they actually
get married so
yeah like i said to each other if i was
in that position i might would just go
ahead
get the paperwork done just so legally
you're married and
you can have an actual party later yeah
to to to keisha's point and to what you
were just saying
the what they they could do anything
they could fly away they can do anything
but the one thing that they have
access to and can't afford is something
that
regular people may not have which is
access to great lawyers
right i don't think that there's any
sort of legality if one of them gets all
that is already taken care of
through lawyers they're they're well
protected we just don't know what
they've spent on lawyers to sort of get
that protection
the wedding's a whole other thing right
the wedding's the pretty part but yeah i
agree with you keisha it's just a bad
look
whether they do it or you know and
everybody's completely safe and they
followed all the protocols
it's just a bad look yeah for sure
and i want to see gwen and all her
fashionista glory honey i'm like girl
i need you to have the problem yeah
photographer
give us the images we need the content
honey because it's going to be amazing
and also
they've been waiting five years um gwen
is what fifty
fifty year how old is why i think she
just i just think that
yeah she's a hundred trash she's amazing
but um i think at this point you're
probably like
five years you know we're locked in this
crib together and like
we're chilling who cares like granted
she needs to have her fabulous moment
yeah if you got
engaged in the fall you're probably
looking at a summer wedding anyway so
they're not really
delaying things yeah it's the other
people have been doing like jlo has been
delaying for
how long at this point jlo yeah i know
yeah kobe's one of the excuses